[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut sortir du débat
franco français parce qu'il ya des
rapports internationaux entre la france
et la turquie qui se passe très mal des
relations qui sont dégradées sur
l'affairé libyenne sur le fair syrienne
ça se multiplient alors il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui la turquie est dirigée
par erdogan par son parti et que les
français sont plutôt opposés à cette
cette lecture de la gestion de l'état
turc est de moins en moins laïque et
c'est une des raisons qui conduit
effectivement à ce qu'il y ait une sorte
de d'affrontements sur le terrain
français par rapport à la petite
communauté turque qui ne représente que
90 personnes ont rappelons le c'est à
l'état français de concernant la
question de savoir s'il fallait
interdire cette association d'évaluer si
elle représente véritablement un risque
au regard de l'ordre public et même de
la sécurité publique
autre chose est donc le débat autour du
financement de lieux de culte ou ou
d'école que cette association n'est pas
seul à porter et qui pose parfois
problème
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d' école hors
contrat ou même si les programmes
scolaires sont censés converger avec
ceux qui sont encadrés par l'éducation
nationale
pour autant le risque c'est celui d'une
communautarisation d'une partie de nos
concitoyens de confession musulmane et
leur mise à l'écart par l'entremise de
ce type de démarche
voilà c'est plus sur ce fondement là où
l'on doit regarder effectivement cette
question
on parle beaucoup de d'exclusion de ou
de volonté soit disant des fêtes de
volonté de séparatisme comme si les gens
qui étaient des minorités fragiles les
plus faibles les plus pauvres et les
moins argentés du pays à savoir la
communauté arabo musulmane
pour ce qui concerne les maghrébins et
la communauté turque en ce qui concerne
les gentils mais plutôt de l'ess si ces
gens-là représenterait un danger il ne
représente en aucun cas un danger mais
ça pose la question et après question à
savoir qu'est ce que vaut l'éducation
dans les écoles que j'appelle moi il
certaines très fort les écoles poubelle
de la république dans les écoles dans
les quartiers défavorisés dans
lesquelles effectivement les anciennes
elles existaient et c'est d'éduquer
difficilement des enfants et qu'est ce
que valent les écoles confessionnelles
comme on les appelle aujourd'hui donc
les écoles qui ont une dimension
religieuse mais qui sont privées et qui
garantisse on le voit à tout le moins la
réussite des étudiants et dans l'école
averroès par exemple qui dans la même
région une réussite éclatante puisqu'il
faisait je crois pendant trois années
consécutives à le fait partie des
meilleurs établissements de france
donc la question se pose sa voix
responsable droits en tant qu' en tant
qu'individu citoyens de ce pays d'être
éduqué dans les écoles privées ou pas et
la question dont on parle aujourd'hui
c'est sous couvert soit disant de
menaces fantasmagorique qui n'existe pas
en vérité sous couvert de soft power
turque dont les moyens restent quand
même limité alors voudrait interdire ces
écoles moi je réponds que c'est
absolument pas à l'état de différer là
dessus on est envahis cité la laïcité
c'est quoi séparation des aiguilles
d'une tasse à ne pas dire interdiction
éducation par les églises ou par les
autres cultes oui alors là ce que je
viens d'entendre c'est malheureusement
le déni de talent et des rêves la façon
dont on ferme les yeux sur l'islamisme
d'une certaine manière parce que il ya
comme une continuité entre le
communautarisme c'est à dire la mise à
part d'individus murs des communautés
derrière lesquelles les endoctriner
heures peuvent parfaitement travaillé à
capter des individus au mais je vous
vois fut donc dodeliner de la tête mais
je suis désolé il ya des morts dans ce
pays
l'idée du terrorisme et c'est bien
précis c'est quand même si blaise a pas
dire que tous nos constituants confiant
musulmane serait suspect mais il ya un
véritable phénomène
il ya une continuité qui a été prouvée
par plusieurs rapports officiels qui
donc indique que le communautarisme est
le principal terreau de la
radicalisation
on va pas tous nié ces écoles hors
contrats dont mégots russe
qu'une des associations porteuses et y
effectivement installe d'une certaine
manière derrière cette façon cette forme
de mise à part me proposez quoi
retrouver des groupes de pression donc
c'est de ça dont il s'agit donc ces
écoles si elles servent à fabriquer du
communautarisme
elles servent à fabriquer ses murs
derrière lesquels d'ailleurs les
individus perdent leurs droits et leurs
libertés puisque ce sont des chefs de
clans les chefs religieux qui parle à
leur place ce qui est prouvé ses séides
de nombreux travaux comme c'est une
bernard rouge et or on n'a pas besoin
d'aller chercher bien loin et des
rapports sénatoriaux et les rapports des
rigoureux où il ya et derrick byars donc
fait un lien entre l'islamisme
la radicalité l'éducation moi je vous
dis que l'éducation permet d'éviter
précisément cette radicalisation
je vous dis que dans les quartiers
l'explosion n'a pas été voulu par les
gens qui vivent puisqu'on est exclu de
fait qui ira à lui à louis-le-grand dans
un quartier qui re a envahi 4 c'est
interdit kiev qui freinent prépa les
profs n'en parle même pas on nous parle
toujours des mêmes établissements pts
dans le meilleur des cas
donc ça c'est les réalités d'un système
qui est parfaitement pensée pour dire le
fils d'ouvrier et le relais sur la
question sociale restera oublier le fils
d'immigré qui donc ouvriers restera
ouvriers ce sont des réalités monsieur
ensuite quand on part les attentats vous
avez beau me dire c'est faux ce que j'ai
dit les attentats qui ont eu lieu en
2015 ont été produits par des enfants
perdus soit la pluie belge soit la
réplique française le royaume belge
fuseaux et la réplique française donc il
se passe quoi on a des paumés qui sont
souvent soit l'ancien délinquant sur
cette île heures de ce rappeur qui vont
des armes pour tuer des gens
gratuitement et qui sous couvert soit
disant d'une idéologie qui ne maîtrise
même pas une maîtrise pas la rabine
corps prétendent se battre pour une
idéologie parce que leur vie est fichu
il ya une vraie question sur la place
des deux de nos concitoyens de
confession musulmane ronde
d'abord le fait que chaque concitoyen
quelle que soit sa confession est donc
aussi nos consignes profession me donne
puissent choisir leur façon de pratiquer
leur culte et ne se la voit pas imposé
par une communauté
donc c'est pour ça que je ne parlerai
jamais de communauté arabo-musulmane moi
parce que précisément c'est à cela que
concours des associations comme liligo
russe
c'est ce saut c'est une logique de
communautarisation de mise à part sur
des codes qui ne sont plus les codes
républicain donc on est amené à
s'interroger sur cette question s'est
très
importe donc